when did you last go to the dance I
don't know so I think like certain parts
of my life are like super adult and then
other parts of my life it's like wow put
a diaper on that girl how adult am i I
don't know how do you define that word
how clean of my room I don't live at
home I feel like that's pretty adult I'm
pretty like regimented in my life in a
way that I wasn't in my early 20s I'm
gonna guess that I will get a 75 I don't
want to say like a specific maybe like
yeah in the 70s I think oh my gosh
on average comfy tastes whooping - you
cook for yourself never coz I don't cook
there was like a month where I was like
really good at cooking dinner for myself
Indian food delivery it's just so good
if you had a kid tomorrow Lord Jesus as
a father how well do you think you would
be able to deal with it I think the kid
would be dead within the day like where
would I take it to my apartment that's
not about being a dolt that's about
being a specific type of like
self-sacrificing and responsible but I
hope to never be have you ever booked
your own flights yeah of course
oh my gosh I'm an adult what like person
in their 20s hasn't booked their own
flight okay my boyfriend puts up a plate
do you know how to bleed a radiator I
don't even know what that sentence means
no I do not know no because that sounds
terrifying Wow
oh my goodness 41% adults okay I got 75%
adult mmm and they're basically a big
kid in a full-size body I think that's
all true I think what it is is me and my
boyfriend making one adult together sue
me why don't you I mean I'm only 22 jeez
also I'm convinced that people over a
hundred percent adult really don't have
any fun in life